let's talk about Syria when Donald Trump
announced that the United States
military would be leaving Syria a lot of
different questions came up we were
wondering well why right now why now as
opposed to at any other time what
happens to the Kurds because if the US
military bails on Syria even if we want
them out that is going to open up the
Kurds to significant abuse from Turkey
what will Turkey do geopolitically as a
result of this how does Saudi Arabia
play into this entire story and how does
the Shamal Kichijoji killing Jamal
khashoggi killing potentially relate to
this are we even really leaving because
you'll remember after Donald Trump said
that American troops are leaving Syria
we heard from national security adviser
John Bolton oh yeah no I mean yes we
might leave at some point but only when
this whole list of things happens
including the defeat of Isis with
Trump's at which Trump said did happen
and Mike Pence said did happen but John
Bolton said did not quite yet happen so
all of these scenarios combined with the
sort of haphazard nature of Donald Trump
saying we were leaving the resignation
of Defense Secretary Jim mattis it all
was a cluster F I think you all know
what I'm talking about at the same time
I've been seeing on cable news Eric
prints appear and make the case that US
military should be replaced with
mercenaries in Syria now why is this
relevant well for a few reasons
Eric Prince if you don't know who he is
he is number one the founder of that
paramilitary mercenary firm that used to
be known as Blackwater he also happens
to be the brother of Donald Trump's
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos and
he is also an increasingly notable
talking head on cable news talking about
Syria and it just so happens that Eric
Prince who reportedly has a net worth of
more than two billion dollars by selling
private war around the world it just so
happens he has a solution to both get
Americans
soldiers out of Syria which he thinks is
a good idea and to keep the Kurds safe
and to keep fighting Isis which is that
his mercenaries can go in it's the
perfect plan right he has been more and
more of a presence on television I saw
him on CNN about a week ago with Erin
Burnett
he appeared on FOX Business where he
straight-up said send in Academy with an
I that is the renamed former Blackwater
which I think had an intermediate
renaming as well something with an ex
like there was a G service yeah XC
that's exactly it
he said if there is not some kind of
robust capability to defend from a
ground invasion from the very
conventional power that the Iranians and
the Syrians have our allies there will
be smashed and his solution is
privatized the war send in the
paramilitary mercenary types and this
hasn't been his solution for how many
decades at this point path so this is
sketchy not only because he's Betsy
DeVos his brother it's sketchy because
he's been wrapped up in attempts to
create that back channel between Kushner
and the Russians via a meeting in the
Seychelles you might remember Eric
Prince's name coming up there and all of
a sudden now Eric prince reappears
saying I've got a perfect solution to
get us out of Syria well he has all the
right ins being
Betsy DeVos his brother and he's making
the rounds on cable news so that's some
great auditioning there the problem with
this of course is that there's very
little oversight I mean Blackwater can
get away with things that maybe the
military can't get away with and this is
probably going to be the new paradigm if
we pull out our troops from Syria
someone else is going to take their
place unfortunately and that's what he's
pushing for us so yeah there are two
stories here as Pat is pointing out one
is this guy in particular has been
horrible for a very long time and now we
can sort of explain Donald Trump's
haphazard Syria decision potentially
right this is all hypothetical to quote
Rudy Giuliani we could hypothetically
explain it by saying well part of Trump
specifically choosing
now is the time to do this is that it is
a coordinated way to hand cash over to
his Education Secretary's brother Betsy
DeVos his brother Eric Prince that's one
story but this isn't just Trump I mean
Trump might be particularly corrupt and
crony istic in this particular example
but this is the military-industrial
complex right decade after decade these
organizations Blackwater X E and now
Academy the same organization this is
why many around the world consider us to
be the bad guys to use a really
unsophisticated term and Eric Smith Eric
Prince is one of the head guys that
makes the world see us that way and
again two billion dollars selling
private warfare around the world and
this is actually a recipe for never
leaving Syria okay that's the most
important thing to understand Trump
claims the priority is we're getting out
of Syria
period doesn't matter what happens and
we can debate whether that makes sense
getting out in order to send in Academy
and start paying the mercenaries to be
there that is a recipe for them being
there for 15 or 20 years in some
capacity continuing to make Eric Prince
an even bigger billionaire than he
already is how relevant do you think
Eric Prince and his presence advocating
for this and his connection to Trump's
cabinet is to Donald Trump's haphazard
decision to get out of Syria let me know
make sure you're following me on
instagram at david pakman and while
you're there if you have an Instagram
account follow the David Pakman show as
well at David Pakman show today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list
and whether you're trying to get ahead
in your career maybe you want to learn
new skills that will make you better at
your job you might just be exploring a
new hobby and you're trying to find new
ways to be creative in your personal
time skill shares the perfect place to
fully immerse yourself in whatever
you're trying to learn I really enjoyed
the class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]